nous sommes à la 20e édition de la
remise du prix de l'histoire du sénat et
sa marque l'attachement profond de notre
institution parlementaire ou au travail
historique au travail des historiens
le jury a été heureux de saluer un livre
de très bonne facture qui jette une
lumière nouvelle sur un moment de la
colonisation
sahel et sarah au tournant du 19e et du
20e siècle et qui le fait avec un talent
qui nourrit d'abord par un accès à des
sources très originale par une plume qui
est délié la restitue tout un monde avec
un effet de réalité tout à fait
remarquable
[Musique]
c'est un livre sur qu'est-ce que la
colonisation et surtout qu'est-ce que la
domination coloniale comment
concrètement les européens ont fait pour
occuper envahir et prendre possession
d'état puissant qui existait avant leur
arrivée au 19ème siècle dans ces régions
le livre tente de regarder ça au plus
près cherche à reconstituer commencé
monde se sont rencontrés et comment la
domination s'est imposé
le choisissons toujours les élus ce que
nous primons à partir de trois critères
d'abord la qualité du style ensuite
l'originalité du propos et enfin et ce
n'est pas la moindre des choses puisque
nous sommes au sénat la capacité de
nourrir un civisme nourrir une réflexion
sur ce qu'est notre vouloir vivre
ensemble bref de données dda profondeur
de champ à nos débats d'aujourd'hui se
livrent le fait excellemment
les choses que j'ai particulièrement
apprécié dans ce prix c'est son aspect
civique qui paraît extrêmement important
dans nos métiers aujourd'hui
d'historiens l'historienne cette
attention portée à comment l'histoire
peut aujourd'hui permettre de nourrir la
réflexion dans nos concitoyens et pour
moi aussi une valeur que je partage avec
on ne peut pas prendre de bonnes
décisions dans le présent sont sans
avoir une bonne connaissance de
notre histoire et cette connaissance
elle doit reposer sur un travail
scientifique menée par les historiens
[Musique]